hi everybody oh hello here we are stay
back stay back you foul Beast there we
go see that's so cool help me out there
more people can do the anchor thing Oh
nom nom nom nom the main mast cells
still need to go down oh there down
there down there down we're sailing
which island are you going to the
challenge the bars one in the distance
okay are we emptying it this was the
best idea I don't know I can usually
walk straighter line than this oh my god
okay oh you're gonna hit that rock your
unit that rock I think it's gonna be too
tight just go just go now you speak out
you're gonna see oh I found the
captain's quarters this is mine hi ok so
the sales blocking my vision so you need
to tell me where to steer I'm looking at
the water chat shut up guys guys you
gotta get off go go to the boat go to
the mo my god
let the spell
oh man the cannon
oh yeah
like you're a very great
we're sinking Oh Judas we're gonna drown
its water down here what do we do what
do we do I'm a no bail bail bail new
recruits we think of ya there's a ship
to the left to the left oh my god go
down yeah xbox one s starting at 299